on est heureux de partir parce qu'on
sait qu'on va on va faire le boulot pour
lequel on a été formé mais à côté de ça
on appréhende un petit peu parce que
forcément peut-être que on trouvera pas
tous à la maison
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Guillaume bonsoir bonsoir
alors que la France retire
progressivement ses troupes
d'Afghanistan l'heure est au bilan 88
morts mais pour vous soldat des troupes
d'élite le bilan c'est que l'Afghanistan
a été la plus belle expérience militaire
de votre carrière vous en êtes revenu ni
amer ni traumatisé bien au contraire
pour vous dites-vous l'AFGA c'était
vraiment le top exactement vous nous
raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Guillaume romanoir
vous êtes né le 20 février 1985 à Paris
père commercial votre mère travaille
dans la poissonnerie qui appartient la
famille depuis plusieurs générations et
donc vous n'êtes pas issu du tout du
milieu militaire au départ du tout alors
à l'école vers 6 ans vous commencez le
sport foot natation handball athlétisme
ouais c'est vrai que j'ai toujours fait
du sport depuis le plus jeune âge et
finalement c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup servi par la suite alors
j'avais 12 ans encore vos parents
divorcent vous décidez de vivre avec
votre mère et heureusement les activités
sportives vous aide à surmonter cette
période un petit peu compliquée de votre
vie à 14 ans vous commencez la boxe
française et à 16 ans la box
thaïlandaise vous comprenez très vite
que vous êtes pas fait pour les études
Guillaume disons que j'étais pas
spécialement mauvais mais je savais que
j'allais pas rester très longtemps voilà
à 17 ans vous partez habiter chez votre
père et en première vous décidez donc
d'arrêter le système scolaire vous dites
je voulais un job dans lequel j'étais
sûr de pouvoir m'éclater je voulais
accomplir quelque chose d'utile pourquoi
pas servir la France déjà je savais que
c'était un métier qui me correspondait
de pas de par les activités sportives
qu'elle propose alors vous retrouvez sur
une base militaire près de Bordeaux avec
une cinquantaine de garçons de votre âge
vous décidez de tout donner pour ces
tests car vous savez que les premiers
seront orientés vers les unités commando
c'est-à-dire l'élite de l'armée quoi
exactement bien entendu quelqu'un qui va
être un petit peu en surpoids ou
quelqu'un qui va être dérangé
psychologiquement ne sera pas envoyé
devant des unités des unités commando
alors les démarches de deux jours sans
s'arrêter avec 60 kg sur le dos à
l'arrivée au lieu de dormir on vous fait
faire des exercices et quand vous allez
dormir on vous réveille au bout d'une
heure ou deux avec des grenades à plâtre
bien sûr entre autres il y en a beaucoup
qui abandonnent
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans ce
genre d'unité c'est 80% en tête 20% de
physique même si la douleur physique
il n'y a pas de surhomme tout le monde
l'a subi mais ça passe avant tout par le
moral et dans la tête oui c'est
entraînement difficile guerre facile
évidemment quand on va partir sur les
territoires étrangers des territoires
hostiles on a on n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur il faut que les gestes
deviennent des automatismes alors en
2005 je vais t'envoyer en Côte d'Ivoire
donc en zone rebelle alors là c'est une
opération de maintien de l'ordre de
collecte de renseignements auprès des
des chefs de guerre vous dites je tire
même pas une seule balle vous êtes déçu
de pas avoir tiré pas du tout on est là
avant tout pour aider un pays à se
reconstruire et aider les populations
alors en retour vous reprenez votre
entraînement vous travaillez
l'intelligence situationnelle pour
réagir au stress dans les conditions
extrêmes ce que vous appelez le grill il
faut que les gestes deviennent
instinctifs pour pouvoir réagir
correctement
le jour où ça va clasher alors vous
retournez ensuite quelques temps en Côte
d'Ivoire et puis on vous prépare pour le
Liban vous apprend tout du pays dans
lequel on vous envoie la géographie la
politique
les techniques de combat vivent on part
pas la fleur au fusil non effectivement
on a sur une mission de 5 à 6 mois on va
avoir 5 à 6 mois de préparation quand on
arrive sur place il faut qu'on sache de
quoi on parle qui on est en face de nous
et dans quel milieu on va évoluer alors
le Liban sera votre première zone de
conflit difficile parce qu'en fait
là-bas il y a des souterrains qui sont
des caches d'armes donc vous êtes à la
recherche de ça évidemment il y a le
Hezbollah qui est tout-puissant vous
cherchez à collecter des renseignements
sur les leaders du Hezbollah alors il y
a aussi un truc terrible que vous
racontez c'est à dire qu'il y a des ce
qu'on appelle les sous-munitions c'est
assez des bombes qui sont remplis de
petites bombes et qui exposent quand on
marche dessus vous dites des fois quand
on voit une vache exploser dans un champ
c'est parce qu'elle a marché sur une
sous-munition l'intelligence qui ont eu
les gens qui ont largué c'est
sous-munitions c'est qu'ils des ont
largué à très basse altitude ce qui fait
que toutes les sous-munitions sont
maintenant dans les branches d'arbres
etc et une fois qu'elle retombe elle
nous pète à la gueule ça peut être assez
dangereux alors là vous êtes au Liban
alors pour le sexe c'est un peu
compliqué hein parce que dans l'armée il
y a 15 % de femmes mais vous vous n'y
avez jamais goûté il y a les filles
locales évidemment c'est vrai qu'en
Afrique autour des bases militaires il y
a pas mal de prostitution mais vous vous
êtes pas dans les bases militaires vous
êtes beaucoup plus loin dans les pays
musulmans vous dites on ne croise jamais
une femme la seule solution c'est la
main droite
quand même
non enfin pas pour ma part en tout cas
pour certains jeunes qui s'engagent à
l'armée qui partent sur des terrains des
terrains hostiles certains ne rentreront
pas la maison il y a des jeunes qui ont
18 ans qui vont rester sur place
il y a des gens qui vont gagner entre je
sais pas 1200 et 1400 euros pas plus sur
le sol français je parle il se déplace à
l'extérieur ils vont être ils vont être
payés il faut 1,5
alors après le Liban et votre dernière
mission en Côte d'Ivoire vous recevez
enfin votre ordre de mission pour
l'Afghanistan alors votre mère est
paniqué évidemment mais vous êtes très
heureux moi je suis très heureux parce
que je vais fermer un petit peu un cycle
c'est à dire qu'on sait que en
Afghanistan à l'époque c'est la guerre
on est heureux de partir parce qu'on
sait qu'on va on va faire le boulot pour
lequel on a été formé mais à côté de ça
on a pris on a un petit peu parce que
forcément peut-être que on trouvera pas
tous à la maison alors arrivé à Kaboul
la première chose qu'on vous donne c'est
un gilet pare-balle ça annonce la
couleur de toute façon on le voit tout
de suite en arrivant c'est une
atmosphère très pesante c'est une
ambiance particulière on sent que les
pays en guerre depuis très longtemps
il y a beaucoup de relief l'Afghanistan
c'est que de la montagne et du caillou
donc ouais on a un petit peu
l'impression d'être sur Mars en arrivant
voilà adrénaline commence à monter là
pas encore
c'est vrai qu'il fait -20 en décembre et
50 en juillet quand même ouais l'hiver
dure très peu de temps décembre janvier
il fait très très froid mois de mars il
fait hyper chaud donc c'est un climat
très compliqué on monte tout de suite en
altitude on est très vite à 3 4000
mètres cagoule c'est déjà si j'ai pas de
bêtises à 2700 mètres d'altitude on est
tout de suite mis dans le bain ouais en
ce qui est compliqué c'est de faire la
différence entre les Afghans et les
aliments c'est quasiment impossible les
talibans sont des villageois c'est des
mecs qui sont habillés comme les autres
parfois il dissimule même leurs armes de
leur par dessus donc oui on a beaucoup
de mal à les distinguer la plupart du
temps vous évoluez dans les montagnes
avec 80 kilos sur le dos et un jour donc
un accrochage arrive alors c'est des
insurgés qui tirent une requête sur un
village où se trouve des troupes
françaises et là vous dites c'est
bon là ça commence à péter donc là vous
y êtes quoi ouais première sortie ça
fait deux trois semaines qu'on est sur
le territoire la première mission et à
ce moment là ouais à ce moment là on se
dit bah c'est ça il est 9h du matin
pendant les six mois durant lesquels
vous serez en Afghanistan vous irez neuf
fois au feu et certains accrochages
durent 5 heures quoi c'est quand même ça
peut durer très longtemps ouais ça peut
durer très longtemps on s'en rend pas
forcément compte
dans le feu de l'action avec
l'adrénaline le stress etc on va pas
leur passer vous vous rendez compte que
lors de votre premier accrochage vous
n'avez pas bu donc vous apprenez à boire
et puis surtout à économiser les
munitions effectivement ouais si si
c'est pour tout cramer
la première fois s'il reste 10 heures de
mission à faire et qu'on tombe sur un
groupe après ça on est mal vous avez tué
des gens
tués c'est un terme que j'aime pas
vraiment parce que on peut être amené à
rencontrer des groupes insurgés si on a
en face de nous quelqu'un d'un peu
virulent enfin un groupe un peu virulent
et qu'on doit on part d'un point et
qu'on doit arriver à un point B que ce
groupe se trouve sur sur ce chemin là
effectivement on peut être amené à avoir
une une très haute cadence de tir
jusqu'à destruction de la cible vous
avez une idée du nombre de cibles que
vous avez éliminé pas du tout et puis à
vrai dire je sais pas vraiment compter
on avait une mission à remplir il
fallait pas se mettre sur notre route
voilà le fait de tuer les talibans
est-ce que ça vous déculpabilise parce
que c'est quand même des mecs comme ça
qu'on fait sauter le World Trade Center
donc de toute façon ce sera lui ou moi
donc dans ce genre de situation je
réfléchis pas quoi pas de remords pas de
regret pour un soldat vous dites
4 mois au Carton c'est mieux que 4 mois
de vacances c'est un peu provocateur
mais ceci dit quand on nous propose ce
genre de mission c'est un petit peu
l'aboutissement d'une carrière et puis
alors il y a des souvenirs il y a des
souvenirs incroyables par exemple un
jour les soldats des deux bords les
talibans et vous vous arrêtez de tirer
pour laisser deux femmes traverser un
village ça peut arriver ça peut arriver
ceci dit c'est pas fréquent alors le
retour à la vie civile passe par Chypre
avec visite chez le chez le psy pour
détecter s'il y a des syndromes
post-traumatiques vous ça va moi ça va
mais il faut rappeler qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont traumatisé
pour ceux qui rentrent et puis chips
c'est des gonzesses aussi on a essayé de
les trouver malheureusement
mais bon on allait rentrer sur Paris
trois jours après donc ça allait faire à
3 jours au retour justement vous recevez
la croix du combattant et la croix de la
valeur militaire est-ce que vous êtes
interrogé en fait un jour sur le bien
fondé de l'intervention de la France en
Afghanistan via ce droit d'ingérence que
les Occidentaux s'optent 3 assez
facilement finalement si l'intervention
n'avait pas eu lieu en Afghanistan ça
aurait pu être plus grave que ça ne
l'est aujourd'hui sur le territoire
français
mais vaut mieux aller faire la guerre
là-bas que de la faire ici d'accord
alors en retour vous êtes crevés mais
vous dites un an plus tard je serais
peut-être reparti bien sûr même six mois
après
alors aujourd'hui vous montez un resto
avec votre cousin en Floride mais
peut-être qu'un jour vous repiquerez au
truc peut-être un service privé de
sécurité en Afrique des choses comme ça
quoi pourquoi pas vous avez pas de venir
mercenaire comme Bob de ARD quand même
c'est parce que nous réserves l'avenir
peut-être qu'un jour
quelqu'un jour je pourrais je pourrais
être amené à repartir sur des terres
connues ou inconnues c'est pas on verra
je pensais une phrase qui est au
monument de la résistance à Paris de
Jean-Paul Sartre qui dit le choix que
chacun faisait de sa vie était
authentique parce qu'il était en
présence de la mort c'est une phrase
magnifique sur la résistance et et voilà
une grande admiration pour tous ces
hommes et ces femmes qui défendent notre
pays et chapeau
merci de votre témoignage et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu